bitcoin and ethereum so you know the top
two players in crypto but what about the
cardano network's coin ada ada is an
altcoin meaning it's an alternative to
bitcoin and is named after the 19th
century mathematician ada lovelace who
is considered the first computer
programmer late this summer a surge in
interest in ada pushed the
cryptocurrency to the third largest
behind bitcoin and ether ethereum's
currency during the rise ada reached a
market capitalization of more than 90
billion dollars and rose to a high of
more than three dollars that's nearly a
two thousand five hundred percent
increase in price on a year-over-year
basis that's primarily driven by retail
investors and i think a lot of the ones
that i talked to are saying
i want to kind of find the next bitcoin
so maybe that's cardano's ada token
given the crypto market's volatility the
third largest change is often but with
nearly 6 000 cryptocurrencies in
existence this year why is cardano's ada
one of the few breaking through
we'll explain
cardano describes itself as a third
generation blockchain platform you can
think about the blockchain generations
similar to the evolution of the cell
phone bitcoin the first generation is
like the flip phone it was revolutionary
in its creation but only does basic
things the second generation ethereum
1.0 that's like your first few
smartphones it offers apps but is kind
of slow to load the third generation
cardano and ethereum 2.0 want to be more
like phones today where speed and
usability are crucial the key difference
between the first generation and the
third has to do with how the network
works
bitcoin runs on something called a proof
of work mechanism which runs something
like this
miners not those ones but people who set
up computers allow the system to work
their computers simultaneously race to
guess a complex sequence of numbers in
order to validate a block of
transactions
the miner whose computer wins is awarded
bitcoin and records the validated
transaction on the blockchain ledger a
fancy word that essentially means the
online record book but as bitcoin prices
rise so do the barriers to entry for
miners so we're seeing
companies fully dedicated to mining
we're seeing miners taking over
warehouses and factories to set up
mining facilities while secure this
system requires huge amounts of
processing power
simply because it requires all mining
computers to work on the same puzzle and
it rewards those with more computing
power
just how much power
in a year the bitcoin network uses about
the same amount of electricity as
washington state we've seen proof of
work increasingly come under scrutiny
because of the energy intensity that it
uses this is one of the biggest
challenges of the first generation of
crypto and a main reason why cardano is
breaking through
cardano uses a different system called
proof of stake a system also adopted by
ethereum's second model ethereum 2.0
which is expected to be fully rolled out
in the future the proof-of-stake model
is um
i think a very exciting prospect for
people who are in the space because it
uses an entirely different system in
order to verify transactions on the
blockchain in cardano's proof of stake
model ada owners use their own holdings
to help validate transactions this is
called staking or delegating think of a
stake as a commitment to keep the
cardano network operating and secure to
earn ada users join a stake pool either
one they've made or another users not
every user in the stake pool is
responsible for verifying transactions
instead one user a pool operator does
the work on behalf of the group cutting
down on computer activity so in short in
first generation crypto every computer
races to solve one math puzzle in third
generation only the stake pool operator
does the work but the proof of stake
system isn't the only factor that helped
cardano break through
cardano recently introduced something
called smart contracts to its system
with an upgrade it calls alonzo smart
contracts are seen as game changers
because they allow the blockchain to
host other operations again think of a
smartphone it's similar to the idea of
an app store except with a blockchain
these apps are called dapps or
decentralized apps and there is no
company like apple or google in between
the user and the application instead the
smart contract has programmed code to
facilitate agreements and transactions
between the user and the dap users hope
cardano's adoption will allow it to
better compete with the ethereum network
where about eighty percent of dapps are
built
but all that traffic has created issues
the reason that ethereum has faced some
scrutiny this year is just because there
have been there's been so much activity
on the network that there's been more
congestion and higher transaction fees
in order to try to transact on the
network so the idea for cardano is to
take the ethereum model and make it more
scalable while cardano's promises may
sound great in theory they've yet to
undergo the most important test
time we'll have to wait and see you know
how successful people are able to use
the platform in order to
[Music]
you know build decentralized
applications and create non-fungible
tokens the introduction of smart
contracts is stage three and a five-part
plan according to the platform's roadmap
still to come are upgrades on
scalability and governance investors
have to keep in mind this is not going
to be a steady investment but i think
people who like to trade amid volatility
that's one of the draws the blockchain
engineering company behind cardano iohk
warned that expectations need to be
managed with this upgrade so how smart
contracts will impact cardano in the
long run
time will have to tell